all right joining us now is North
Carolina Congressman Dan Bishop he
changed his vote to support McCarthy on
the 12th ballot Congressman it looks
like the Democrats pep rally is going to
be coming to an end tonight but uh you
met with McCarthy I understand right
before this vote can you tell us
something about what happened behind
closed doors
well Laura as you may be aware we've
been working the group of 20 that were
original holdouts were working to change
the way their house operates and we've
got an agreement to do that and what
we've been working on is nailing down
every piece of that agreement and we met
with leader McCarthy immediately before
coming to the floor for a final
conclusion of that agreement so it is as
one person who's in position to know
told me today as a transformational
agreement for the way the house operates
and for the policy priorities and
legislative strategy it's going to be
undertaken by the house Republican
conference so that we can finally stop
the 1.7 trillion dollar Omnibus
Appropriations bills and start making
this place work in the way it should
yeah I wish it was 1.7 billion obviously
trillion congressmen uh but right now
we're here yeah that's all right what
you know a billion trillion this is
Washington
um Congressman what what I think we've
seen over the last few days is the
curtain pulled back
on the process of Washington
and most people do not follow and I'm
glad they don't because they have real
lives they don't follow the nitty-gritty
of how bills get to the floor and why
don't we know what's in these bills and
why don't we have departments like
Veterans Affairs have its own budget why
is everything so fuzzy and is it not the
case that these congressmen and Senators
prefer it most of them to be very opaque
so they aren't held accountable for
votes on immigration or votes on uh
covet or votes on you know they pick
your poison they'd rather say oh I just
voted to keep the government open
right Laura you know in fact what's a
real tragedy is that media all across
this country described what was going on
here is being chaos and dysfunction no
what you've seen for the last 15 or more
years in the way this place operates
that's dysfunction doing the same thing
the same way will not produce any
results What's Happening Here is exactly
what should happen men and women of
Courage standing up to make changes to
this institution functions properly and
we meet our responsibilities to the
American people it's going to be tough
because we've got to control spending
we've got a provision that I'm most
excited about to have a genuine Frank
Church style committee we had to I
personally have been to fighting over
every detail of that to make sure that
committee can get access to everything
that it needs and uh and it's been it's
been a tough and bruising process that's
exactly what should be happening and
media ought to be celebrating it all
over the country and the courage of not
only the 20 but but beg the question why
aren't there 30 40 50. what more could
we have gotten and that's a great shame
but I got to tell you it's a great
celebration for me that we've achieved
this result and now I'm glad to see the
speaker speaker's race concluding
obviously we're all in suspense about
exactly how this will turn out yeah well
Congressman I'm just glad you all have
to work on a Friday night like the rest
of us okay so you know Congress the
congressmen are used to flying home on a
Thursday you know and getting home for
the weekend no now you're working just
like everybody else all right
Congressman we appreciate it I'm just
teasing it thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else